Yakub um yeah they happen Feeny uh
genzou okay happy birthday hey happy
birthday happy birthday happy Hank Oh -
my oh happy Hank good morning Hank it's
the most wonderful day of the year tanco
DeMayo happy 30th birthday Hank you're a
tough guy to shop for nerdfighteria
spent the longest time thinking about
what we should get you we did get you
this corndog shirt hope you like that
but that didn't seem like it was enough
so for the longest time we were tortured
what will we do for Hank for his 30th
birthday but then we realized you like
oxygen and so to increase the overall
oxygenation level of the world
nerdfighteria planted more than 10,000
plants and trees for you on six
continents even Henry got in on the act
he planted these Indiana native
wildflowers for you then now Hank enjoy
meeting some of the thousands of Hank
trees and Hank plants that your awesome
has inspired us to bring into the world
happy birthday the years are going by so
fast it really is we will turn and we'll
be so cold grown-ups and have mortgages
and children I hope we all gain
worldliness and wisdom and maturity but
I hope most of all that myspace falls
into obscurity
I hope our profiles all go dead in tune
and distant servers a monument to our
youth although lacking its observers
your page will be an empty shell when no
one is behind it I hope your myspace
stays forever and I hope that your kids
find it
now I hope that you forget about your
myspace I hope with sips completely from
your mind and I hope it stays up long
enough for the next generation to find
and I hope that it embarrasses your
children hope their bratty friends are
forwarded around and I hope that you
forget your password so you cannot take
it down your kids think your vaguely
square it will be so much clearer when
they laugh at the pictures you took in
your bathroom mirror they will not know
your favorite band or any of the others
who is this Soulja Boy you reference
who's the Jonas Brothers the Marvel and
how old you are they'll raffle at your
outfits
your style make pass as vintage in the
future though I doubt it now I hope that
you forget about your MySpace I hope
it's completely from your mind and I
hope it stays up long enough for the
next generation to find and I hope that
it embarrasses your children hope their
bratty friends are forward and around
and I hope that you forget your password
so you cannot take it down
I hope you're cynical kids say holy crap
this is great these comments date all
the way back to 2008
I hope they dig through your pictures
and find something might call
compromising I hope seeing their mom in
a swimsuit or smoking a hookah isn't too
traumatising but it will be past their
comprehension they'll ask did grandpa
not give you enough attention
[Music]
I knew the hell is John the guy knows
everyone hope that you forget about your
MySpace
I hope it's completely from your mind
and I hope it stays up long enough for
the next generation to find and I hope
that it will humble you forever and I
hope your kids don't let you live it
down and I hope that you forget your
password so you cannot take it down they
might go through your top eight friends
read your comments at the most I only
wish that they could see the inane
bulletins you post I'm going to take
these shoes and plant them and then
hopefully I'll get shoe trees god I hope
they're Doc Martens happy birthday Hank
Hank tree
Hank happy 30th birthday and this is my
version of the topsy-turvy tomato plant
happy hey Gautam I go I would have
bought these really pretty purple
flowers that are in a hanging basket
Hank planned of all happy birthday Hank
we tried to get his nerdy flowers as
possible
happy birthday Hank I wake up in the
risk of it came the bump that's on my
head my feet are cold as they hit the
floor I don't think I'm anymore John
shouts Hank I don't mean to scare you
but I think that people bump in dirt
bacteria settle down
clear the area let me look out the
window cuz I don't know what it is that
I can
this place is like internet but it's all
3d there's no place that I'd rather be
then live in
with friends making videos heavily under
fat dairy aha
dressing up like I need magic taking
sexy gota crowd talking all the women
who like men and drops you like you're
up let's go down the nerdfighteria
center where the rules are big with
Pearson everyone is so ready and there
are no perverted creeps
cuz I don't know what it is that I can
this place is like
but it's all in 3d
that boots that perfectly god I love
smoothies made me tea on earth by Jeremy
[Music]
there's certain books you should obey
don't ever at DBA and now I come to
think of it let's take that world sucked
out of it we don't care what I am about
a nurse outfit good that we've got our
awesome island with awesome season
awesome awesome but I don't know what it
is that I can't see
this place
in 3d
there's no place down
[Music]
we're living here with my nerdy friends
making videos happily on a ferry aha
but area
hi Hank I know you like useful plants
and stuff in your head so I planted some
parsley put it on my head
happy birthday Hank happy birthday I
plan to do some of these plants which
will be named the Hank plants happy
birthday Hank
happy birthday Hank happy birthday hey
happy birthday hank dftba breathe the
oxygen you think of now water
happy birthday Hank your jugglers slash
sword swallowers for VidCon we planted
three tomato plants because we wanted to
raise the oxygen levels and because my
wife likes Tomatoes happy 30th birthday
Hank this is the tree that I blamed it
for you happy birthday Hank I planted
miracles for you
this is begonia Hank there are times
when the paper starts off empty cuz
there's so much we don't know how to say
but if we think about it it will all
come out if we remember it was waiting
for today these are things we want you
to
[Music]
you should know the world is getting
smaller you should know how much these
people care and I know it seems like
it's a lot to be but we just thought you
should be aware
and you should know that this is just
beginning
you should know we're in it for the
fight and we find some day it's done in
then it's because it all turned out
we things we want you to know
I was taught that we're all getting
older but I've learned and I know that
it's not true
just take all these days and let them
melt away
because we spent them here
with you you should know
the things we have accomplished and you
should see the fondness we all share
you run aground then just turn around
and we'll all be standing there
these are things we want you to
[Music]
there are times when you hear a thousand
voices and it spins and nothing feels
the same but when they moved on when
they've hushed and gone you remember
that we all know your name these are
things we want you to know
happy birthday Hanks happy birthday hey
happy birthday Hank birthday happy Hank
of denial this is my plant his name is
Hank happy birthday hang on mio
happy birthday Hank a birthday happy
hunker tomorrow I'm gonna go find some
peace pocket happy ankle DeMayo
everybody let's go to thumbdrives
aquatic Hank
these are nerdfighters sign out first
because like in groups life